سحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حاره
الياسمنا في بلده القديمه في نابلس في
الضفه الغربيه
بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وجنوده الاحتلال
وافدت مصادر محليه الاخوه
لتامين جنودها في المنطقه
من رام الله
حاليا وما الذي اسفلت عليه عمليه الاقتصاد
في هذه الاسماء مياده تحاصر قوات الاحتلال
الحاره الغربيه في البلده القديمه
وتحديدا ما تعرف بحاره الياسمينه وهي كبرى
الحارات القديمه في داخل ازقه البلده
القديمه وفقا مصادر محليه لازلنا بانتظار
تحديث جديد من الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
ولكن يبدو ان مسعف فلسطيني اصيب برصاصه في
الظهر اثناء محاولته الدخول مع طواقي
الطبيه الى داخل الحاره الغربيه كما كان
قد اصيب قبل حوالي نصف ساعه شاب فلسطيني
همم قضيه رصاص في الرقبه وتم نقله الى
المستشفى الان قوات الاحتلال تغلق كل
الطرق المؤديه الى المنطقه الغربيه في
الحاره همم في داخل البلده القديمه تمنع
احد من الدخول او ال همم الخروج تطلق
الرصاص بشكل
اشواقي ولكن يبدو ان هناك اشتباكات مسلحه
في هذه الاثناء هي اشتباكات متقطعه بين
مقاومنا فلسطينيين وجنود الاحتلال في داخل
الازقه والحرارات تسمع ايضا اصوات لتفجير
عبوات محليه الصنع لانه كما نعرف خلال
الاشهر الماضيه بان الشبان المقاومين
كانوا يضعون سواء في نابلس او جنين عبوات
محليه في حال قيام القوات الاسرائيليه همم
الدخول الى داخل البلده همم القديمه في
نابلس وجديد ولكن ما يحدث اليوم يبدو انها
عمليه عسكريه حتى الان لا تتضح الصوره ولم
يظهر اي بيان عن الجيش الاسرائيلي من هو
المطلوب في هذه العمليه ولكن هناك محاصره
لاحد المنازل في داخل حاره الياسمين فقط
للتوضيح حاره الياسمين هي حاره معروفه في
البلده القديمه في نابلس هذه الحاره
القديمه قدم التاريخ وبالتالي الازقه فيها
الضيقه جدا والمنازل متراصه لا يمكن
الاتصال باي احد داخل ااه المنطقه هناك
الجميع اغلق هواتفه ولكن فقط شيء اخير
مياده ما يميز هذه العمليه انها تاتي
صبيحه الاعلان عن تشكيل حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو وبالتالي قد يكون هذه الرساله
الاولى من هذه الحكومه او قد تكون ضمن
الاطارات
في اطار العمليات اليوميه في داخل الضفه
الغربيه شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله
مراسلات الجزيره